desinformation ganz genau also ich war
vor ein paar tagen in einer
diskussionsveranstaltung mit
schülerinnen und schülern meines
wahlkreises und ein schüler stellte mir
die frage was ich eigentlich davon halte
dass ukrainische flüchtlinge
russischsprachige menschen in
deutschland angreifen und die frage hat
mich sehr verwundert weil ich noch nie
davon gehört habe und auch bis heute
noch nicht davon gehört habe dass
ukrainische flüchtlinge menschen
angreifen bei uns vor allen dingen auch
nicht russischsprachige ich habe dann
recherchiert und festgestellt das ist ja
wohl ein fake video gab in nordrhein
westfalen wo eine frau berichtet auf
russisch von einem 16-jährigen ukraine
von einem 16 jährigen jugendlichen der
von einem ukrainischen mob totgeprügelt
wurde weil er russisch sprach es hat
sich dann herausgestellt dass dieser vor
fallenden stattgefunden hat die polizei
hat auch direkt dementiert hat auch dazu
aufgefordert dieses fake video nicht zu
teilen und was ich an dem fall ganz
besonders interessant finde ist dass sie
frau eigentlich nicht mit böser absicht
gehandelt hat zumindest sie das so aber
dieses video sich innerhalb kürzester
zeit so stark verbreitet hat dass es
insbesondere auch in den russischen
kanälen sehr stark verbreitet wurde das
ist ein ganz klarer fall von des
informations kampagne wie wir ihn ja
auch schon in der vergangenheit kanten
der fall lisa ist so ein fall und
desinformation hat ihm das ganz klare
ziel menschen zu verunsichern es hat das
ziel das vertrauen in den staat zu
beschädigen und deshalb bin ich der
meinung dass chris information ein
angriff auf unsere demokratie ist und
wir deshalb unbedingt und dringend den
staat stärken sollten in der
wehrhaftigkeit bei solchen
desinformationskampagne meine these ist
putin führt nicht nur einen krieg mit
waffen er führt auch ein
informationskrieg und ich habe die große
sorge dass deutschland immer mehr zum
schauplatz auch dieses informations
krieges wird und das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
herr palmer haben sie vielleicht eine
idee was man dagegen tun kann
so finde ich sehr überzeugend
vorgetragen hat die analyse ist bestimmt
richtig die antwort was man tun könnte
finde ich erheblich schwieriger es gibt
ja den besucher über das netz
durchsetzungs gesetz im internet
strafbare inhalte zu löschen waren
aufwendiger diskussionsprozess ob sich
sowas auch fähig die uns ausweiten liese
und ob man das technisch beherrschen
könnte ist eine frage die ich nicht
beantworten können aber dass man da
nicht einfach wegschauen darf das würde
ich genauso durch klaus wie gefährlich
ist dieser des informationskrieg bild
wurde ja zum beispiel als beispiel
russland gesperrt auch wie gefährlich es
ist in deutschland die fans und bild hat
für sich eine antwort gefunden nämlich
alles was wir recherchiert haben und in
deutscher sprache in unserem heimatmarkt
publizieren wird auf russisch übersetzt
und auch sozusagen auf russischer
sprache publiziert jetzt ist da die
erste adresse russisch sprechende
menschen in deutschland da gibt es ja
auch sehr viele putin verstehe und putin
anhänger die auch nur russisches
fernsehen gucken also ich glaube dass
das boot teil von boris palmer richtiges
das ist sehr schwer aber es muss halt
jeder dass dagegen tun was er tun kann
medienhäuser können so reagieren
gesetzgeber könne sich genau angucken
was möglich ist und was man machen kann
eltern können ihren kindern sagen alles
was du im netz fließt könnte falsch sein
ob es noch eine zweite quelle gibt etc
lehrer könnten
sachkunde stunden dazu benutzen das wird
dann für den schulen ja auch schon
gemacht im zuge einer medienerziehung
hier ein kritisches bewusstsein zu
schaffen so dass die angreifer
wenigstens nicht auf willfährige
empfänger treffen sondern auf ich sage
jetzt immer ein großes wort gebildet die
das einordnen können das würde schon mal
helfen und ermutigt finde ich auch nicht
zu sagen dann geschieht was möglich ist
und man kann kann eigentlich nichts
machen
gesetzgeberisch glaube ich es ist sehr
sehr schwer weil
wie in jeder form der kriminalität der
angreifer immer ein ticken schlauer ist
als der verteidiger der einbrecher immer
ein bisschen schneller wächst als die
polizei da das gilt da sicherlich auch
das sind schon ganz schön raffiniert
netzwerk am werk die das flächendeckend
unter die leute bringen ich glaube nur
ein kritischer grund geist hilft da erst
mal als gegengift ich glaube auch ein
anfang wäre schon gemacht wenn wir uns
überhaupt dieses bewusstsein hätten wenn
wir uns das vor augen führen würden dass
es ein großes problem ist aufklärung ist
auch wichtig wie sie sagen und
gleichzeitig ist sind wir auch da
tatsächlich in einem dilemma weil in
denen wir aufklären über die
falschinformation ich habe ja gerade von
einem fall berichtet lief er ihren wir
die fall das ist glaube
ich glaube auch gar nicht sagen dass ich
jetzt die lösung habe und das rezept für
das thema aber ich glaube wir müssen
darüber sprechen und wir sprechen nicht
darüber wir sollten darüber anfangen zu
sprechen auch wenn wir darüber sprechen
wir werden es nicht los wenn sie wenn
sie einen heuschnupfen haben können sie
den heuschnupfen tage lang diskutieren
da wird sie nicht fern aber
ich will noch mal einer sagen was mich
schon wirklich auch bewegt wenn
desinformation sozusagen um sich greift
wie sie es beschreiben und ich glaube
sie beschreiben ist richtig dann könnte
ja auch ein weg sein dass man mit der
richtigen information im land des
angreifers zu gange es mir wird bis
heute nicht klar warum es nicht viel
flächendeckend im westen gelingt die
nachrichtliche deutung des westens ich
sage es mit aller zurückhaltung denn da
ist natürlich auch propaganda drin na ja
nicht alles was die ukraine tolles
machen war vielleicht so toll und alles
was ihnen weg geschieht aus und über das
sie selber berichten hat vielleicht
wirklich so stattgefunden aber warum wir
nicht in der lage sind den russen die
dafür empfänglich sind sie haben vorhin
eine mehrheit der russen als extrem
putin treu beschrieben da stimme ich
ihnen zu die haben nämlich gewählt die
mit 55
so ist es aber das sind ja dann auch
noch ein paar andere und die müssen wir
doch alle medienunternehmen
politik erreichen können früher hätte
man aus flugzeugen flugblätter
abgeworfen
es ist klar dass das heute aus
verschiedenen gründen möglicherweise
nicht die richtige
maßnahme ist aber was ist eigentlich die
digitale informations kampagne die wir
mit voller power von
den schlausten leuten von facebook und
google dass die sagen ja wir sind da
abgeschaltet haben längst ein weg
gefunden der information wir dürfen auch
unsere offensive nicht vergessen für die
richtigen nachrichten anstatt immer nur
zu sagen um die falschen nachrichten die
desinformation unterwandert sozusagen
unser wissen das finde ich extrem extrem
wichtig und das macht mich auch drauf
wir sagen immer die bösen anderen stadt
dass wir uns wege überlegen wie wir
guten ich sage dass ein bisschen sogar
analysiert weil vielleicht sind wir
nicht immer so gut wie wir denken aber
um beim beispiel zu bleiben anstatt zu
sagen wie wir guten zum zug kommen
können wird man ist mein
lieblingsbeispiel war immer wie kann nur
der amerikanische geheimdienst das handy
von frau merkel hätten das macht man
doch nicht unter freunden meine frage
war wie kann es eigentlich sein dass die
deutsche bundeskanzlerin ein handy hat
das fremde mächte hätten können